plus d'un an après l'élection de joe
biden les américains restent fortement
divisés c'est ce que démontre une
nouvelle enquête d'opinion sept
électeurs républicains sur 10 estiment
toujours que l'élection a été volé
donald trump un sondage qui montre aussi
une grande fracture sur la perception
des événements du 6 janvier au capitole
les explications avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas boni
aux etats-unis la situation n'a pas
véritablement changé depuis la dernière
élection présidentielle une étude d'une
université du massachusetts montre
l'étendue des divisions au sein du
peuple américain ils sont par exemple 71
% parmi les électeurs républicains à
considérer joe biden comme un président
illégitime ils sont encore une large
majorité parmi ces électeurs a estimé qu
il y a eu des irrégularités lors du
dernier scrutin présidentiel et puis
concernant la journée du 6 janvier 2021
et les événements au capitole enquête
montre là encore une différence de
perception entre les démocrates et les
républicains
chacun accusant des personnalités
différentes pour leurs responsabilités
et alors que 86 % des démocrates
soutiennent les enquêtes en cours dans
ce dossier plus d'un républicain sur
deux s'y opposent en fait l'un des
aspects les plus intéressants de ce
sondage c'est qu'il montre que ces
chiffres n'ont quasiment pas évolué en
l'espace d'un an un aspect canalise l'un
des auteurs de cette enquête écouter
alors que nous concluons une année qui a
vu se produire une attaque choquante sur
le capitole des états unis ainsi que des
affirmations persistante et sans
fondement de la part de l'ancien
président et de ses flagorneurs sur le
fait que l'élection présidentielle de
2020 a été volé nous continuons de voir
les républicains et les démocrates vivre
dans deux réalités diamétralement
opposées cet état des lieux de l'opinion
américaine est riche d'enseignements
alors qu'en 2022 se tiendront les
élections de mi mandat des élections au
cours desquelles donald trump prendra
certainement beaucoup de place du côté
républicain le positionnement vis-à-vis
des propos de l'ancien président sur la
dernière élection sera source de
controverse surtout que les électeurs
indécis semblent majoritairement
hermétique à la théorie de la fraude
électorale et puis du côté démocrate
certains alerte déjà comme l'a montré et
l'élection du gouverneur en virginie la
stratégie qui vise à concentrer les
attaques sur donald trump pourra
certainement ses limites en tout cas ce
scrutin ne devrait pas atténuer la
fracture au sein du peuple américain qui
semble quasiment irréparables sur ces
sujets